Pamela Geller is here with David Litman
human rights activist passionate human
rights activists at the UN can you tell
us a little bit about yourself David
well I started uh in 1986 at the uh UN
in Geneva and that was then called the
commission on human rights and there was
the subcommission that takes place in
the summer so it's something in the
region of 10 weeks in a year as an NGO
then the main representative as I was
for the world Union for Progressive
Judaism which stopped after a uh problem
with the American ambassador who
happened to be Jewish at the time in 91
and then I went to non-jewish
Nos and have been with the association
for World
education uh which is not Jewish of
course since 1997 and back with the
world Union for Progressive Judaism
since the year 2000 because they found
no one else who was able to speak for
them uh in an adequate way so uh my
experience has been that
uh I always quote Spinosa every man has
the right to think what he wants and to
say what he thinks and there are certain
things that are not said at the council
because they are considered taboo
subjects why they're taboo subjects
because they are embarrassing they are
are I don't say politically I say
religiously
sensitive and so you are not expected
even amnesty and Human Rights Watch and
all the other uh very respectable NOS
will keep off the question of um
anything that touches on shabia law uh I
don't have to mention them all but
stoning of
women uh honor killings
female genital
mutilation a marriage at 9 years old in
Iran Yemen and you name it
Sudan uh because you do have to refer to
shahia and that is a crime of Les I
would say l OIC the organization of the
Islamic conference and I am probably the
only one I won't say who has the courage
because once you've been to a nice good
English public school and you've captain
Cricket tennis and boxing you don't even
consider these questions you build an
Empire and you fight back and you say
what has to be said and I I always
appreciate the now and again an
interpreter says to me it's difficult
when you quote Shakespeare and Churchill
and you're going a bit quick but go on
speaking we're all listening I put my
hand against my heart and I say I have
to go on because in fact if I don't deal
with certain questions of of this nature
for instance the wushi fatwa 1989 you
would have thought that someone would
have had the courage to go on hammering
home but no three states spoke very
briefly no one mentioned Wishy by name
and uh I I spoke two or three times and
I always tell the funny story that uh
someone told me you know they could bump
you off so I went straight to the
Iranian delegation we in it was St
Valentine's day in 1989 and I said um
they say that you're going to bump me
off Mr Litman why would we want to do a
thing like that I said I don't know but
you should bear in mind that if you did
everyone would know it was you they
laughed so much that 20 years later last
year came back the young secretary who's
now Ambassador Iranian you know dressed
in the usual Style on his way to New
York he mentioned Iranian Jews he was
going to see there how are you ET I said
you know Mr
Ambassador sometimes when I think
ofet and I always pronounce him with the
mad with the stress Ahad he must have
been put in there by the
mosad now if I tell you that he laughed
it will give you an idea no one else
would dare do that because they would be
afraid I treat it as a joke and he did
too yeah because you're speaking their
language and they know they can't fool
you by lying through their teeth it
won't work but they don't like what you
say David did they not stop you from
speaking were you not ejected uh from
the UN you want to tell us a little bit
about that yes well that was a very
dramatic moment um it was during the
Durban 2 as they call it the
followup uh to the Durban Conference of
19 uh of 200 uh um
2001 9911 yeah um so this took place in
April
2009 and you've only got two or 3
minutes I can't remember if it's 2 or 3
and I was speaking for the association
World education and the world Union
dealing with another very interesting
thing uh to to give you the atmosphere
if I may call it right uh there there
was a very nice film where uh I Won't Go
Back it's a French filmer 50 years ago
with the word
atmosphere but uh what happened was that
uh the slave trade which is
always uh spoken about the transatlantic
slave trade with exhibitions at the UN
never will they speak about the
Arab uh thousand year old slave trade
and the
ottoman uh system of taking the
Christians as slaves regularly which
went on for centuries which is why
there's such antagonism between the
serbs and the Turks for so long and the
Greeks now uh they're speaking about
paying um indemnities that America and
the Europeans should pay for what they
did Forgetting that not only were the
Arabs taking slaves until the end of the
you know Church who describes it in 1899
as a journalist but it's not uh they
have an exhibition and they won't put
that on exhibition you will only see the
slave not the slave trade now in Saudi
Arabia or in
morania not the Arab slave trade in
history but only the transatlantic slave
trade so I spoke about that stressed
that spoke about uh uh other things
judeophobia which is rampant in the Arab
Muslim World which I never fail to speak
about and one or two other issues very
briefly and then I got up
finished and I happened to see one or
two ambassadors or their secretaries or
whatever counselors that I knew and no
Norway I think Denmark and I I I gave
them my statement and as I'm going out
the um African very well-dressed
African representative of the
organization of the Islamic
conference he saw me and I said to him
you know I'm sorry I was a bit harsh on
the OIC he said Mr Litman you always are
but give me a copy of your speech of
your statement so as I'm handing it to
him two guards grabbed me by the
arms that the
Secretariat had decided that since I was
follow this Distributing
material meaning anything it could have
been a Playboy or something I'm
Distributing material I couldn't I was
literally frog marched at my age out of
the big uh main hall where highly
salassi came in
1936 so quite
embarrassing incredible and then try to
take away my badge but isn't this a bit
boring for your no it's interesting
because it tells me just how biased un
is that even just to say something uh
you know truth begets hate well they'll
say it's the rules they'll say you know
the rules so my question is am I allowed
to give uh a compliments if if I'm asked
for my card what is exactly is
Distributing uh um
uh Distributing material they won't tell
you no I you think you have a I I I mean
I'm giving you this I'll perhaps go back
to it but just to tell you a little
before that I had another fight I was
being stopped regularly all my papers
were being
searched now there's no rule to my you
they can say we don't want things being
handed around because there would be
maybe the fallong gong would come in
with papers and put them out so they
took the chance to do it with me now the
funny thing happens when they come in
I'm going through and all the guards are
very friendly to me but they've been
given instructions you put a uniform on
someone and give them instructions yes
and you know anything can happen and
this Sophie a very nice girl there she
she they're searching my stuff and
they're searching un written statements
that we've made that I happen to be
carrying 40 and my statement I'm going
to give and a fellow who doesn't even
know how to read English is trying to
read read my text I said no forget it I
grabbed it and I put it in my bag I said
this is becoming ridiculous Sophie where
is this law from she said there's a l
we've been told I said I want to know
the
exact number it's got to be a director
General ruling so she gave me a number I
went and got it it have nothing to do
with it it's just to check if anyone
happens they think he might have
arms so I after I said that knowing that
the head God was standing next to me I
said if that ever happens to me again
I'll make a public complaint uh and a
press conference because it's
intolerable that we're being searched
for papers since that moment having
stood up firm it doesn't happen anymore
but if you don't do it it does so what
happened was I was ushered out and they
said we want your badge and I had a
light stroke then I wasn't in good
shape so um I had the right to have a
car to come in the doctor's permission
and they wanted to take everything away
from me and I simply said look
um I want to see it in writing they were
completely taken back the people you
know the gods and I said yes it's got to
be in writing otherwise you cannot Act
without Authority from someone above you
I want to see that Authority Well that
took some time and luckily I won't name
names but someone very high up
who was very friendly to me decided that
too much was too much I mean I went
through a kangaroo court session it was
very disturbing they wanted to take away
my badge for 3 months unbelievable it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable I've
written it up you'll see it all on Jihad
watch and in the end this fellow told
the guy who was responsible for that and
I won't name any names simply to stop
and the result was it stopped and now
everyone is treating me once again with
great respect why because I stood up
didn't allow myself to be uh brow beaten
bullied yeah
bullied uh I remember when I was at
school there was a bully a Dutch fellow
when I was very young I was good at
boxing and he kept bullying me and then
he said he wanted to box me publicly in
the school you know School of 500 boys
and I was one of the better boxers but I
was young and what happened was he hit
me with his fist but with the inside of
his fist and he stood there thinking I
would fall and I didn't and he got one
in the plexus and another one in the
chin he went down since after that he
became the best friend I've ever had
because he knew it wouldn't work well
the same thing's happened it doesn't
work at the UN I've got people on my
side who admire or appreciate that
things have to be said and there are few
people for instance
the ladies they're always fighting
against FGM but they can't touch the
question that for instance in Egypt I
mean it's fonic it's nothing to do with
Islam per se but according to the
tradition uh the prophet is going by a
tent and he hears a little baby
screaming what's that he ask this is the
Hadith and they say uh they're doing
this you know they're cutting out
everything so the prophet if you have to
do it do it with a light hand result is
Persia you don't have it Syria you don't
have it Morocco you don't have it but
all around the gulf you have it because
they use the shafia uh I've got the text
here in Arabic which I never speak as a
historian without the proof so in
Egypt if I had to ask you what is the
percentage of poor girls who were
mutilated every year what would you
guess 10 20 30 what would you guess no I
know the answer from you from me 96% I
it's so horrifying when but because
there's a law against it and we're only
saying that Alazar must pass a fatwa if
tantawi had the courage not to
say something vague because the last
fatwas that came out 4951 81 they say
circumcision is
obligatory uh excision or call it what
you like is the parents should do their
Duty now uh illiterate parents or
mothers uh they do their Duty they do
what was done before and they're sending
from Europe they're sending back
children and doing it in Europe you know
how many in Geneva alone 1500 wow 15,000
in Switzerland hundreds of thousands in
Europe
Girls 3 million a year UNICEF figures
I'm giving you not me
UNICEF but the girls the women who were
dealing with this very respectable very
hardworking doing a fantastic job they
tell me they can't touch that if they
mention anything to do with Islam the
people who were cooperating with them
because they were against it Mrs Mrs
muak and all the others they're against
it but they
can't do anything from a religious point
of view and so when I speak and I went
up to her she's an African lady from
from Kenya and I went up to her and I
said I hope I didn't embarrass his no
she said go on meaning keep on you're
the only one who is dealing with that
aspect are they dealing with the UN
Human Rights are they dealing with the
chairo Declaration what what are they
using and how how pervasive has this the
Cairo declaration well the Cairo I'm I
was the first one I must be a bit you
know what Oscar wild said I don't make
make a virtue out of false modesty so I
can say that I was the first one to
realize what was happening with the
Cairo declaration which came in in
1990 it's called the Cairo
Declaration of Human Rights in Islam
right it started in Teran in 1989 with a
meeting of foreign ministers 26 of them
I remember and finally became came the K
declaration which is now accepted and
they're bringing in a new Charter which
is based on that everything is
conditional
upon the Sharia articles 24 and 25 are
very clear now since there is no
equality between Muslims and
non-muslims and no equality between
Muslim women and Muslim men in Sharia
and all sorts of things can happen you
can be stoned
uh by uh you know under the Sharia it's
clear that there is no relationship
whatsoever between the universal
Declaration of Human Rights of 1948 and
the international covenants which are
very respectable and very clear and the
Cairo Declaration of Human Rights which
I've analyzed I I did it for in Middle
East quarterly islamism goes stronger
with the UN but ever since it came out I
was the first one to raise is this
quoting a Muslim liberal lawyer who
denounced it at the
time uh his name will come back to me
dang his name it's it's not Simon D
who's the famous fellow we'll be
speaking at our wonder he's wonderful we
got him to speak at the UN in a big
parallel
conference he's wonderful he he came it
was very moving because we had a a big
collateral
conference as NOS it was the
international humanist and ethical Union
the associate and World Education
Association World citizens Etc and we
had many we had aan herei Ali we had Bor
uh I was there Professor Jansen he came
uh Simon Deng and the subject was
victims of jihad it was Muslims it was
um uh
women uh
and uh and and
apostates apostates and we took the
whole day it was and and poor Simon he
came and he started speaking about
himself and he was so taken by a emotion
that he broke down and someone had to
read his text for him that was in
2005 so we we're doing what has to be
done and uh fortunately you know it's
not I mentioned two NOS I speak I speak
for others but I'm back in the saddle I
was in bad shape I didn't want to go
anymore but I realized that you know you
have a duty to carry out in life and
I've had a number a few and this is this
is one of them which must be done
because otherwise and they are slowly
gaining I can tell you they're slowly
taking
over the council everyone realizes it
it's um pathetic patic it's
um I say it it reminds me you
know the I always give the example of
the Hans Christian
Anderson uh fairy tale of the Emperor
who asked the tailor to prepare a suit
and they had no material but they told
the emperor that they addressed him so
the emperor believed what he was told he
went out but he was naked and all the
people seeing the emperor
naked they couldn't do anything until a
little child raised its hand and said
Mommy the emperor is naked so I say the
council is naked all these people are
naked they
don't want to recognize the obvious and
I give you another example they they
have now is this of interest of course
they they have what they call uh
complimentary standards it's another way
for the OIC and the Muslim countries and
not only to
show what's called cultural
relativism so you know you have the
Swedish delegate will get up I it was in
October I think I I I put it up it was
on a couple of
sites uh the new English review Jihad
watch Etc last October and the question
was uh
freedom of
religion freedom of opinion and
expression and the
Swedish delegate gave a very nice uh
explanation of what we stand for you
know the judeo Christian uh
Enlightenment values as defined in the
Universal declaration and all the rest
and then I got up you know a lot of
people spoke you heard Saudi Arabia it
was a joke it sounded you know Islam has
always done this Islam was the first to
do this you know if you listen to what
the uh Muslim delegates say about Islam
having introduced human rights with the
famous constitution of
Mecca you just have to read more about
that and you'll understand what really
happened but still that's what we get so
uh then came my turn and I didn't even
know one could speak there I saw an
American indigenous American you know
Indian if that's the right it's not the
right word who was who's always
attacking America we get along well I
mean he's he's from Alaska you know why
should America have taken our land you
know it's genuine it's authentic and so
we get along well and I suddenly saw him
I said what are we able to speak he said
yes we're only three noos so I kept
raising my hand I was able to speak
something like 10 times and one of the
times I asked them look I've been
hearing with great interest freedom of
religion here and don't forget we've got
America Canada Australia Sweden all the
states were there you know know
about not say all let's say 100 were
there and only three Nos and I said I
would like to ask a question to all the
delegates present and have a an answer
which would correspond uh which would
correspond to the
reality in your states are there any
laws which would not permit someone to
change his religion because according to
the universal declaration and I read you
know everyone has a religion changes
religion do what he like uh I'd like to
know whether there is such
legislation which puts someone in prison
or condemns him to
death or doesn't give him a identity
card which is the case of course in
Egypt and if so surely this is in total
contradiction with what has been said
here and what is in the international
covenants that every one here has signed
and
ratified now do you think that anyone
reacted not even Canada or America
because that would have
embarrassed the Egyptians the Saudis the
Iranians and and then I I asked and a
marriage at 9 years
old you know I always raised it I rais
it in Georgetown University I don't
blame it on Muhammad in medieval Europe
and in other places you married very
long the girls died in
2022 thousand years ago whatever but
today it's part of the law since the Sha
was
toppled in
Iran it's part of the law that you can
marry at 9 years old and you've seen
many cases in the New York Times but how
does this fit in with the Covenant on
the rights of the
child uh you see it speaks about 18 but
then it speaks about it gives the I
don't have it with me it refers to
legislation in you know in each country
and of course in each country it would
be they want totally different when they
tried to change that
law 2000 they tried to change it the
moderate Muslims wanted to raise the age
not to the
Sha know 18 but
14 now what happened the magist the
parliament had a big s
session and the mullers got up and said
we've put so much effort into this law
which
corresponds to Shak we don't accept to
send to change it and since then it has
remained since
1989 at 9 years old because Muhammad
married Aisha uh at six actually with
toys six when I mentioned this in
Georgetown one of the Muslims there went
nuts and started shouting and went out
came back since she was 18 I said I've
never I gave him the all the sources you
know
isak and said look I never heard of a
girl with toys at 18 seems a bit old
surely youve got it wrong I mean it's
clear it's 6 and he consummated the
marriage at 9: but I'm afraid he did
other things with her uh before
consummating the marriage
so that is um something one's not
supposed to say and there was no point
in saying it the only point we have is
today is it acceptable under
international law to permit such
barbarism as female genital mutilation
marriage at 9 years old to an 80-year
old man there a recent case with the
girl ask for divorce at 11 if you
remember it was in the New York Times so
I'm raising these things no one else
will touch it
and they have to be raised and by the
way everyone listens when I start if you
see all the last film even the cameraman
when I was being
stopped by the third time by the
Egyptian to to have me booted out the
cameraman came back to me and showed me
smiling to myself because I knew he
would make a fool of himself and I told
the I joked with the Egyptian ambassador
he's not the Ambassador I said you know
I don't know what I do without your
number
twoo so you know the only thing is to
laugh make fun and
ridiculizar had a description already of
what's happening the new uh since the
mecca conference uh the third Islamic
Summit conference in December 2005 at
Mecca by the way it's very interesting
that we were then I was then in Denmark
about these Danish cartoons with
um uh with rose
Fleming we were five people speaking I
was there with Bator and two or three
others and and there was no big problem
then it was in October it was
only when they
came uh the Mula from not the Mula the
UL came from Denmark and the Arab League
they started to make a big deal of it
they started killing only after the same
thing with the Wy um fatwa humi learned
about it very late uh he you know he
started moving and they started killing
uh people so um the situation is that uh
it's getting totally out of hand however
your new I've forgotten her name you've
got a lady Ambassador now she's not the
incumbent in Geneva but she's leading
the delegation coming from Washington
for the OCC she was very good she was
very firm I went up to her after she
spoke
and I quoted her nice biblical proverb
oh I said Madam oh were as the as the
good proverb says a word fitly said is
like golden apples in a silver frame she
liked it I like it too I know that
feeling I get it once in a great while
so the answer is um it's going down the
drain I believe believe that there is
nothing that can save it my own belief
um and I go
far um I I wouldn't dare do that again
now I could do it two or three years ago
I um you might you remember the world
Disney um films with the famous castle
on the hill this of course is ludvick II
who built it in Bavaria beautiful place
if you've ever been there it's I bet you
didn't know that it's great great place
it's the noin the new Swan uh thing and
so I now refer to the UN as the pales
vanin in other words not the norstein
that the tourists will flock from all
over the world to see what was the
pal but the question of Human Rights I
mean by the way the fellow Ludi II who
built that it so impressed Walt Disney
that he put it on his film um lck II he
used to feel like Louis the 14th Le Sima
the state it's me but of course he had
no he had become a uh a nomin a nominal
Le leader he wasn't really the running
the country but the UN the Human Rights
Council they almost say Le sen human
rights it's us and they refer to
themselves as the um conscience of the
world or the International Community and
I say uh when I was I was AR the famous
French um uh television program cultural
they did a big interview just before the
um famous Durban 2 thing in April 2009
and how would you sum it up and I said
look we're on the eighth floor beautiful
view of the Lake and I said over there
on the other side of the lake Lord Byron
sat with Percy bishy Sher the famous um
shell the famous uh poet with his
girlfriend Mary Godwin then became his
wife Mary shedy and it was raining like
mad I mean I didn't say all this I told
her what I would say and then I said it
but you should have it all because it's
Villa diodati they sat it was pouring
with rain 1816
and Byron said let's write horror
stories he came out with Dracula or
something like that but she came out
with Frankenstein right I know and then
she became his wife afterwards so I
simply said that's I said sometimes I
feel as if
Frankenstein when I hear the nonsense
I'm hearing here Frankenstein has got up
from the Villa diodati where he was
created by Mary Godwin he crosses the
lakes with his long legs comes into the
P schwanstein Palo on his way to the
North Pole so if I may give you a rather
symbolic feeling when I say that now I
could say that a year ago as a joke like
I could say something is rotten in the
state of
this Council and the
Romanian president accepted it as a joke
this the Egyptian tried to use that two
months later to get me kicked out he
insulted the you know I was stopped
three times for no reason and then I
asked the remaining he's very friendly I
mean I said how did Mr Ambassador why
did you have to stop me he said I saw
but maybe I shouldn't say it but it's
two years ago I saw the body movements
of some of the
members of the council and I knew that
it would lead to points of order Without
End because I was dealing with it was
Gaza as usual condemning Israel and they
were working on the resolution and I
came in with the hamash charter and said
the root of the problem is the hamash
charter which is genocidal which has
never been condemned and I've been
condemning it I was the first one to
bring an Arabic and an English
translation the PLO asked me for a copy
January the 31st 1989 6 months after it
came out and and no one has ever raised
it now can you imagine the Jews or the
Christians or the Hindus coming up with
a genocidal chter saying that uh inside
the the the hamash chter article 7 says
uh the last judgment will not come until
a tree and a stone will cry out there is
a Jew behind me come and kill him and
this is article 7 before the famous
slogan about you know the path of Jihad
and in the way of Allah so all I can say
is that um it's
hopeless it's going downhill I don't
think it'll last but I'd like to be
there when we pull down the curtain it's
a bit in fact I I tried to give that
image I'm sorry to be so fluffy this
morning but it's so nice to be in New
York and I remember when they passed the
first formation of religion resolution
the OIC pushed it through and I in those
days you could put things out on the
table and no one would stop you it could
be you know you write something you put
out on the table they they they read it
or they don't and I put out on the table
and and and I said to the thing I
said when Napoleon won the Battle of
aitz in
1805 pit the yango who was then prime
minister he simply said cuz Napoleon
knocked everyone out and it wasn't to
waloo that it was stopped 10 years later
and pit the younger a year before he
died
said roll up that map of Europe it won't
be needed these next 10 years so that
was my quote in
1999 and I say the same thing now roll
up that map of the council it won't be
needed these next 10 years unfortunately
for those who believe believe in the
international covenants and our freedom
of opinion to express it as Spinosa put
it which someone I quote whenever I can
and then they can't stop me they can't
stop you quoting Spinosa would be thank
you David thank you on that hopeless
note which we knew we
knew no I mean we we we we knew it was
hopeless but to get such a reliable
witness such an articulate well it it's
kind I hope I haven't bored your
listeners with too many well our
listeners like to know what's going on
and very rarely do we get someone who's
on the inside who witnesses it firsthand
who sees what's happening how it
happened as opposed to most of us who
just basically have our faces pressed up
against the window yeah but but one
thing is very important don't run down
the whole the biggest mistake is to run
down what the UN is doing in general
wonderful things are being done I I give
if I may a last
example Sudan forbade the use of the
word slavery I always call A Slave a
slave when they were taking slaves I
even represented Christian solidarity
International and they freed up to
85,000 Christian and animist slaves but
if a un delegate had dared speak about
anything
other than
abducted people
children if he used the word slave they
would have cut off humanitarian Aid so
so they couldn't so what I mean is
there's a lot of good things being done
in the UN there is I I no no no I I
don't disagree with you David but what
do you do when you're dealing with
Hitler or Stalin well exactly so so
Hitler was good to his dog so does that
make him redeemable in some way I just
think that if the if food is poisoned or
there's poison in the blood the whole
system is poisoned you seem to think
that without the UN that good things
wouldn't Happ no no no you you can't
yeah but you must understand there
there's there's a lot of Wonderful well
I I I must say this is very important
that you don't you have this system
where the states have their votes for
instance no this is very important
excuse me I was telling too many jokes
before the the uh African States will
have an agreement not the African Union
you know it's about if I'm not mistaken
42 or 50 states they will never
criticize another African State the
Congo the worst most horrible things Sri
Lanka had there was a there was an
article in the Boston Herald just two
two days ago on the what's it called the
Boston Herald is it the the Boston Globe
the Boston Globe you know they were
speaking well the UN must start acting
they don't realize you have the voting
system which makes it impossible to for
inst Sri Lanka a year ago they had
finally had something not just
condemning Israel um but uh on Sri Lanka
and they finally praised the Sri Lankan
Government after what was happening I
just think good men will do good works
and I think the UN is basically a
collective uh negation of of humanity
and I it seems to do such ill it's it's
object its objective is to uh demonize
the delegitimize Israel Israel to me is
you know the uh the bellweather of
humanity well yeah okay I was giving you
the example of when I was stopped you
know dealing with the charter but if you
read what Vio deelo the Brazilian fellow
he was the High Commissioner he was
killed uh in Baghdad with with with 20
people one of the people now lost her
husband she has a little baby it's you
know baby now five years more uh it's a
terrible thing but he what he I keep
quoting him because he pointed out the
reason the commission had to collapse
and what I do is I read what he said in
his last written statement which he also
read because I have it here actually uh
but I you know I could read it to you if
you like what what I we have to close go
close shall I read you the thing from
Papa actually the tape is going so we
have to close we have to say thank you
very much okay anyway he's the man to
follow we must quote the decent people
at the UN who are trying to change it
against all the odds and not blow the
whole thing up what we want you're not
going to because you have the wrong
government in the United States you're
not going to say I don't want the United
States let's be all independent states
it's been wrong for decades it's been
wrong since Zionism is racism but we
could have this
debate we will continue to debate the UN
I am against he is quasi for David thank
you very
much I'm not for I'm for the good things
but